[Music]
google kubernetes engine provides a
managed environment for deploying
managing and scaling your containerized
applications using google infrastructure
the environment kubernetes engine
provides consists of multiple machines
specifically Google compute engine
instances groups together to form a
container cluster kubernetes draws on
the same design principles that run
popular Google services and provides the
same benefits automatic management and
scaling rolling updates and more when
you run your applications on a container
cluster you're using technology based on
Google's 10 plus years of experience
running production workloads in
containers when you run a kubernetes
engine cluster you also gain the benefit
of advanced cluster management features
that Google cloud platform provides
these include Google cloud platforms
load balancing for compute engine
instances node pools to designate
subsets of nodes within a cluster for
additional flexibility automatic scaling
of your clusters node instance count
automatic upgrades for your clusters
node software node auto repair to
maintain node health and availability
logging and monitoring with stack driver
for visibility into your cluster this
hands-on lab shows you how to deploy a
containerized application with
kubernetes engine next up on our quest
is container registry QuickStart
[Music]